on va passer aux trois infos du jour et
on va revenir sur cette histoire qui
avait fait énormément réagir est-ce que
vous vous rappelez à Rennes cette maman
de 48 ans qui a été accusé d'avoir privé
son enfant de 14 ans de soins
d'alimentation encore d'éducation
puisqu'il n'était pas scolarisé et on
l'avait reçu ici la maman c'est
lorsqu'elle a amené son fils aux
urgenence il y a quelques mois après un
malaise que les médecins ont sonné
l'alerte il ne pesait que 25 kg à 14 ans
sa maman donc stéphanie est passé au
tribunal hier elle a été condamnée à 2
ans de prison avec surcis ainsi que le
retrait définitif de l'autorité par ent
vous allez nous expliquer ce que ça veut
dire g parce que vous êtes le le le le
le sol qui avait travaillé sur ce sujet
je crois non Jacques aussi tu peux
Pascal et ben moi j'ai été prévenu il y
a une minute avant de rentrer sur le
plateau que je faisais t PMP normalement
je vais pas faire donc
moyér pas la
proire je dis la vérit la peine de
m'embrouiller j'étais chez le CP j'ai d
chez ma grandère c'est la vérité non
mais tu étais trop trop occupé à être
sur une île déserte avec Ch card
et e non non non non mais je la
connais après une alerte donnée par un
centre hospitalier les Français
découvrent en 2022 l'histoire d'un
adolescent qui viit reclu avec sa mère
c'était des conditions insalu quasiment
sans lumière un enfant cloîré dans sa
chambre une mère de famille soupçonnée
de maltraitance envers son enfant un
enfant qui n'est ni scolarisé ni suivi
médicalement et qui souffre d'un retard
de croissance l'adolescent qui pait
seulement 25 kg mais alors que sa mère
qui était poursuivie pour soustraction à
ses obligations légales et privation de
soins p à comprendre les accusations
dont elle faisait l'objet tout ce qu'on
raconte c'est vraiment tellement
diamétralement
oosé de de notre vécu le tribunal de
Renn a décidé de la condamner hier soir
alors qu'elle a été la sanction
prononcée on en parle ce soir dans
TPMP on en parle ce soir dans TPMP avec
G Verdez notamment elle risquait 7 ans
de prison donc on peut dire qu'elle
s'entire bien parce qu'elle a 2 ans avec
surcis mais néanmoins elle n'aura plus
jamais l'exercice de l'autorité sur
l'enfant ça veut dire que l'enfant est
maintenant placé il est dans un foyer et
elle ne peut plus exercer la moindre
autorité que les les juges ont jugé
préjudiciable à l'enfant c'està-dire que
pour les juge elle est dangereuse pour
cet enfant elle qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire donc qu'elle a été le
retrait définitif de l'autorité
parentale elle n'a plus aucune
responsabilité à exercer envers
l'enfant il peut habiter avec elle mais
ah non non il est en foyé ah non non non
non elle est déch totalement il est
placé en foyer d'ailleurs depuis le
début de l'affaire elle avait été jugée
dangereuse pour lui il était extrêmement
amaigri aucune vination mais parce que
quand
il il avait l'air content d'être avec sa
maman on a jugé qu'il n'était peut-être
pas libre qu'il était sous emprise et
qu'il n'avait peut-être pas le
discernement c'est son état de santé qui
avait alerté quand les médecins
l'avaient vu ils ont dit il faut le
placer jacqu là là où c'est très
difficile à apprécier pour pour être un
peu pour pour jouer le rôle de son
avocat si je puis dire c'est que il
était pas reclu et maltraité au sens de
la dénutrition même s'il avait beaucoup
maigri vous 27 kg mais c'était c'était
un cas non mais elle ce qu'elle explique
c'est que c'était un cas atypique que
elle l'hillait apparemment comme Louis
XIV
que que elle lui enseignait beaucoup de
choses parce qu' elle enseignait
voilà donc ils avaient une façon de
vivre qui était très particulière très
fusionnelle elle était beaucoup dans
l'enseignement et tout bon et c'est
normal que la société à un moment donné
compte tenu de son état physique prenne
cette décision mais
bon il y a aussi des gens qui ont une
façon de vivre je parle pas de la
malnutrition he mais je
par en disant qu'il existait or les
juges ont vu qu'il n'existe pas
administrativement vous savez elle avait
dit ici les néophilippines je l' déclaré
là-bas et C déclaré l'fant exactement et
bien il y a pas de décation existence
légale de C nexiste pas en
franceadistration française connaissait
pas ça c'est parce qu'elle dit elle dit
qu'elle l'avait enregistré au
Philippe voilà mais bon après il avait
il avait il était c'est vrai qu'il était
de père inconnu il est quand même né aux
Philippines et ne peut pas écarter le
fait que même qu'elle est quand même
enregistré là-bas même
sIIT jamais été scolarisé quelque
chose tu sais que c'est pas ce qui est
la règle la règle c'est qu'il soit
scolarisé mais il peut l'être par ses
propres parents c'est c'est ça c'est pas
interdit en qu- que vous pensez de la
décision de la jus son avocat va faire
appel qu'est-ce que vous en pensez pour
moi elle est bonne il fallait que
l'enfant soit retiré à sa mère voil on a
quand même entendu pardon le mot surc
non oui c'est ça ça veut dire qu'il y a
rien définitif ça veut dire
pr recommence
Prelle recommence avec
quire si demain elle fait autre
chose enc une fois pour ce il enevé son
enfant mais sa vie elle est détruite à
ce jeune parce qu'il a été totalement
dans une bulle il pourra jamais
reprendre une vie normale il a été son
enfance il est je pense qu'il est cramé
il
est là où c'est très troublant c'est que
c'est quelqu'un de très intelligent
faire d'histoire qui a appris énormément
de choses il était plongé dans la
bibliothèque toute la journée donc il
avait un intellect quand
même il est heureux forcément parce
qu'il a aucun esprit de comparaison avec
quelque chose de normal donc en fait lui
il sort de là c'est là maintenant que
pour lui il est malheureux parce que il
a grandi dans un truc où il était
complètement biaisé par le le monde que
lui avait créé sa mre non ce qui ce qui
était inquiétant c'était son poids ah
oui c'est s 47 27 k 27 k il il avait
aussi un retard quand même intellectuel
donc même si elle le nourrissait avec le
homeschooling et cetera qu'elle lui
apprenait vachement de trucs ils ont
constaté quand même que pour 14 ans il
avait un retard d'intelligence là elle
est elle est elle est libre oui euh
voilà mais elle n'a plus la garde de son
enfant voilà et elle a 2 ans de surcis
enfin 2 ans de prison et surci est-ce
que il aura elle aura un droit de visite
parce que quand même malgré tout cet
enfant il doit avoir un attachement sa
mère en fait moi la seule chose qui me
préoccupe c'est c'est c'est c'est
l'enfant en fait qu'est-ce qui ressemble
parce que si on l'empêche de voir c'est
exactement ce que dit son avocat il dit
que c'est une décision qui va à
l'encontre en fait de la de la sphère et
de ce qu'ils ont créé tout à l'heure je
parla
fusionutorité parentale c'est différent
c'est-à-dire que par exemple si ton
enfant est malade et qu'on doit te
demander une autorisation pour l'opérer
pour faire une transfusion pour ceci ce
n'est pas à elle qu'on va demander comme
a dit que il était placé elle a le droit
de
visiteite si elle a le droit de visite
ce sera à mon avis le juge verra si il a
besoin que sa mère le voit quand même ou
s'il faut tout couper d'accord et c'est
pour ça que l'avocat a fait appel parce
que lui il estime que cette décision va
à l'encontre des intérêts de la mère et
de l'enfant c'est incroyable c'est comme
dans les films en fait les folles qui
ont un enfant et qu'il le tiennent qu'il
le tiennent dans les les greniers c'est
exactement ça et donc l'attachement oui
parce qu'il connaissait personne d'autre
sans doute que en plus de ça socialement
bien sûr elle le tenait à l'écart donc
là on est plus sur le principe de
Stockholm que sur de l'attachement pur
même si c'est sa mère même c'est sa
génitrice et qu'elle lui a apporté des
choses on retrouve le même un peu le
même phénomène dans les sectes lorsque
des enfants ont vécu selon des préceptes
et des des règles de vie qui sont assez
éloigné des des nôtres mais qui en
réalité ne voi pas le mal et considèrent
que ils ont eu une enfance normale merci
à vous d'avoir réagius on va passer
maintenant à la deuxème info on va
revenir sur la disparition très
mystérieuse et inquiétante de lina 15
ans qui reste introuvable depuis le 23
septembre s'il n a eu aucun gros
rebondissement depuis le weekend dernier
Paris Match a consacré une grande
enquête à cette disparition selon la
journaliste sur place dans le village
l'ambiance est très particulière elle
parle même de psychose dans cette zone
du barrain un reportage qui coïncide
avec les déclarations de cette jeune
femme qui n'ose plus marcher seule
regardez il y a presque plus personne
qui sort le soir à cause de de ce qui se
passe c'est rare qu'il a des personnes
mais sont toujours à deux mais tout seul
comme Lina non moi je rentre en même
temps que ma meilleure amie et je sors
plus et même que le matin je stresse
pour aller à la piste cyclable où je
passe je stresse vraiment je regarde
tout le temps derrière moi s'il y a
quelqu'un ou pas que ça soit à l'allée
ou au retour
oui dans le reportage de de Paris Match
qui est très circonstancié c'est presque
heure par heure avec une description
très fine des lieux et bien elle la
journaliste décrit une ambiance
effectivement qu'elle compare à celle de
la Vologne pour la faire grégoryie en
1984 c'est-à-dire qu'elle dit que les
parents ne laissent plus sortir leurs
enfants que tout le monde se soupçonne
qu'il y a un climat terrible presque de
terreur de panique donc c'est très
évocateur de ce qui se passe dans le
village aujourd'hui voilà elle dit ils
disent dans le village je ne laisse plus
mon Petitfils revenir à Pier raconte une
voisine elle n'est pas la seule à plus
vouloir voir sa descendance emprunter
seu les routes de campagne Les Inconnus
sont regardés avec suspicion un autre
habitant été poursuivi après qu'un
témoignage sur une clio bleu foncé soit
sorti dans la presse notre Clio gris
foncé dit-il a été prise en chasse par
un Riverin au volant de son énorme 44
vous faites quoi sur ce chemin vous avez
une Clio j'ai appelé les gendarmes oui
il y a les secrets des uns et des autres
qui commencent à sortir presque de
l'espionnage on regarde e à travers la
fenêtre et l'article décrit très bien ce
climat extrêmement particulier Lina les
parents ont informé la gendarmerie elle
été entendue par les enquêur cette
semaine Freddy son papa éta avec nous
lundi et elle a été entendue he cette
adolescente oui oui elle a été entendue
alors c'est une des pistes en fait ils
ouvrent toutes les pistes pour les
refermer ou pas pour le moment ils sont
en train de vérifier chaque témoignage
sa crédibilité il y a des témoignages
contradictoires donc il sont en train
d'étendre l'enquête à une cellule
régionale avec des officiers de police
judiciaire qui ont des spécialités
différente pour tenter d'avancer mais
ils ont quand même dit que ce serait une
enquête de longue haleine alors
justement on eu l'impression que ça
bouchait beaucoup le weekend dernier et
là depuis 5 jours alors est-ce que c'est
parce que on a vu que la maman est
intervenue cette semaine elle avait
demandé elle a demandé à ce que les
journalistes arrêtent de parler à Tor
travers de de l'interview et elle veut
reprendre le contrôle global de la
communication que personne ne parle
globalement à par elle voilà est-ce que
c'est parce que aussi peut-être
l'enquête avance mais et que enfin il y
a moins de choses qui sortent et et qui
doivent qui qui font que qui sortent
voilà oui c'est-à-dire que il y a eu
tellement de gens qui ont parler alors
on va dire à tort et à travers certains
ont sans doute raison mais il y a eu
tellement de témoignages contradictoires
que la maman a dit maintenant on arrête
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
pourquoi longue haline parce que c'est
le l'utilisation de la téléphonie qui va
peut-être faire avancer les choses là
oou lina a disparu il y a 3 ans c'est
une zone rural il y a trois antennes
relais autour où ça peut borner donc il
sont en train avec les quatre opérateurs
téléphoniques de récupérer tous les
numéros qui ont borné autour de là où
elle a disparu autour la de la
départementale le problème c'est que il
faut réceptionner tout ça trouver les
identités et voir si parmi ces gens-là
il y aurait d'éventuells délinquants
sexuels mais ça peut prendre du temps
des jours ou des semaines merci en tout
cas Gill pour ces infos et on va voir
s'il y a des infos qui vont tomber ce ce
weekend dans les infos du chour il y a
aussi ces propos d'un un éditorialiste
de la chaîne LCI qui ne passe pas du
tout vous allez voir ils sont pas passés
apparemment il y a eu de grosses
réactions là-dessus hier soir alors
qu'il évoqué un vrai fléo les étudiants
qui galèrent à se nourrir et qui du coup
se rabattent sur les paniers gratuits un
éditorialiste a tenu euh des propos qui
ont énormément choqué sur la toile comme
on dit pour lui la pauvreté recule dans
le pays et il ne veut pas je cite donner
l'image d'un pays où les gens auraient
faim euh mauvais timing ou les moments
où les restos du cœur n'ont jamais eu
autant besoin de soutien regardez des
gens font la queue pour essayer
d'obtenir à manger ils étaient 400 hier
ce sont des étudiants les places sont
prise tellement à l'avance je pens que
les gens sont vraiment dans le besoin de
plus en plus on peut pas rester
insensible à ça Pascal bien sûr qu'on
est sensible au fait que les étudiants
non souvent sont les les premiers
confrontés à ce ce type de difficulté
alors je je veux relativiser je veux
surtout pas qu'on donne l'image d'un
pays dans lequel finalement les gens
auraient faim et ferai la queue à la
soupe populaireah c'est ce qu'on vient
de voir ouais c'est une facilité enfin
vous avez vu ces jeunes gens ils sont
pas non plus dans le dénuement le plus
absolu si c'est pour faire du
misérabilistme ne comptez pas sur moi
alors est-ce que là qui comprennent ce
qu'il dit non non vraiment non bah je je
pardon mais quand il dit c'est une
facilité c'est facile pour personne de
faire la queue devant le Secours
populaire ou devant les restos du cœur
ou devant une banque alimentaire c'est
absolument pas facile j'imagine comme
comme tu dois mettre ton ego de côté
pour aller demander à ce qu'on tu tu
puisses nourrir tes enfants je rappelle
simplement le Secours populaire ce
qu'ils ont dit un français sur tro ne
fait pas trois repas par jour un
Français sur 3 se prive pour que ses
enfants ne se retrouvent pas devant une
assiette vide et un Français sur 5
n'arrive pas à boucler son but et
mensuel et vie à découvert c'est pas
facile il y a sopia qui vraagir làdessus
et je pense pas surtout que en étant
jeune on aimerait manger ce genre de
repas je pense qu'ils aimeraient je sais
pas prendre un fast food ou quoi avec
leurs amis donc je pense pas que ça soit
la comme Valérie une facilité pour eux
oui un étudiant sur deux ne mange pas à
sa faim donc moi je suis révolté par ce
qu'il dit on a l'impression comme ça que
ça passe ou peut-être qu'on exagère
quand on voit les fil d'attente des
étudiants pour manger c'est incroyable
voyait pas avant ce qu'on voyait pas
avant tu vouis dire moi j'arrive à
comprendre ce qu'il dit parce
qu'effectivement ce n'est pas une
généralité parce que si c'est vraiment
une généralité c'est que c'est très
grave ce qui se passe c'est un problème
il faut que ce problème soit réglé avec
des aides ou des tickets rest ou quoi
que ce soit des des choses voilà mais ce
n'est pas une généralité heureusement
donc moi j'arrive à comprendre ce sauf
que c'est en TR c'est en train d'en
devenir une parce que ça montre à quel
point il y a de plus en plus de monde
aujourd'hui quand on voit les que là qui
sont c'est pire que pendant le covid et
et et ces jeunesl ils sont pas là à
faire la fête tu c'est des moments où
peut-être qu'il ratent sur leur cours
c'est des moments qu quiirat sur des des
moments où ils pourrait travailler et
ils sont là à faire la queue à attendre
des heures et des heures pour pouvoir
manger juste se nourrir c'est un besoin
primaire quoi tu peux pas dire que c'est
pas un problème que c'est pas un
problème général puisque selon les
chiffres officiels de l'adresse
l'Institut statistique du gouvernement
un quart des 18 24 ans vit sous le seuil
de de pauvreté en France faut pas
oublier que pourer le du cœur faut
s'inscrire et faut faut prouver que on
est en difficulté financière c'est pas
un hasard on vient pas comme ça je pense
que ce qu'il a voulu dire Pascal péri
c'est que il veut dire que Y a beaucou
pcoup a voilà je pense que ils confond
deux choses c'est un pays où il y a tous
les filets de sécurité y compris par les
restos du cœur et par le monde
associatif donc normalement voilà mais
la réalité des chiffres c'est que c'est
la population qui souffre le plus les 18
24 ans c'est la population qui est la
plus pauvre et il y en a un quart qui
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté c'est
grave'est- que vous voulez non je c'est
un sujet dont on va le plus en plus
parler parce que un an des Jeux on veut
donner une image au monde entier qui
n'est pas forcément celle qui est la la
réalité donc on veut écarter les rats
les punaises de riz qui a pas de SDF pas
de resto du cœur et cetera pour donner
une belle image de la France et c'est
pour ça que on parle de ça en ce moment
ah bah si on peut pas lever le débat
vous me dites tout de suite non non mais
lui c'est vrai que les punaises de riz
ça vachement le débat sommes-nous tous
des petits voleurs c'est en tout cas ce
que confirme la plateforme hotel.com qui
a réalisé un sondage sur ces Français
qui taxe des produits dans des hôtel
chausson produit de beauté des Mans déco
peignoir et cetera plus d'un Français
sur TR a admis avoir déjà volé
des produits dans des hôtels où ils ont
séjourné je sais que vous aussi c'est le
cas ici hein regardez dit la
vérité c'est un nouveau sondage étonnant
qui vient de paraître dans la presse VO
dans les hôtels 38 % des Français
avouent avoir volé des
objets souvent poussé par l'inflation de
plus en plus de Français repartent de
leur chambre d'hôtel en dérobant
quelques objets si les produits de
beauté ou les chaussons sont les plus
subtilisés certains emportent même avec
eux des rouleaux de papier toilettes ou
encore des œuvres d'art pour 2 %
descondés des vols qui peuvent coûter ch
à certains établissements qui estiment
perdre 5500 à 20000 € chaque
année voilà c'est fou ça qui a déjà
volé ça compte les petits savons ou
pas savons ça compte les petits
savonsampoing comp compte tout compêtes
don c'est donné j'appelle tout de suite
la maréchaussée non oui non les
chaussons moi j'adore les cha tous lesou
les pas nous ça la raison c'est pas nous
les chaussons
raison moi j'ai l'impression quand on
paye l'hôtel on pay les petits
Champo chaussons les
Ch les prends savoir tous les sachets de
thé et café
non c'est un crevard un gros rad fait
pas ça c'est un énorme crevard crevard
au prix de l'hôtel Le
Café oui d'accord tu fais partie des 13
% qui volent le PQ aussi non pas le
PQ ma fa ma faiblesse c'est les peignoir
ah
ouir les peignoir ça coûte de l'oseille
voilà donc je vais demander quand même
si et cetera comme je l'ai mis est-ce
que vous allez le laver et si on dit
vous pouvez le prendre alors là je le
prends
personne non mais attendez non mais
attendez les pignoirs personne oui
JeanMichel moi un jour j'ai démonté vous
sais des appareils dans certains hôtels
on passe les chaussures dessous ça se
met en route automatiquement j'étais
dans un magasin de bricolage j'ai acheté
du tournev je l'ai démonté je l'embarqué
Ding ça c'est clairement du appare
génial ça se trouve pas dans le commerce
il y a que dans les hôtels qui en a tu
es parti tu l'as mis dans ta valise
c'est horrible je pas pris sous le BR je
pas con non
[Rires]
plus vous aimez être en peignoir chez
vous c'est une question vous ouais c'est
sympa d'être en pignoir vous baladez
comment chez vous en
peignoir non ça en peignoir je sais pas
pourquoi je vousvis venir à des kilos
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a non non St rien
en dessous non en pignoir tu rien
dessous de l'équipe de France un
PIR du donc quand en PIR vous sortez du
bas prenez pas votre bas en combinaison
de ski bah moi non plus vous êtes en
pignir vous chez vous bien sûr vous êtes
en petit pignoir comme ça bien sûr
nouso ngligé et votre peignoir il c'est
un peignoir les peignoirs qu'on met pour
sortir du bain où est-ce que c'est un
peignoir vous voyez soit voilà il
connait il connait mon peignoir en soit
en or avec les derère dragon ah ouais la
Rambo Rocky BB pas je me balade Jama en
pignoir je déteste
ça quand vous rentrez vous déshabillez
complètement vous êtes comment je reste
comme ça moi cas où il y a une
ambiance reste comme ça tranquille tiens
selon je Sun c'est dire le
soleil bah c'est le pour Mo
[Applaudissements]
ça ben je vous dire il m'a envie don
envie de donner l'info à tout de suite
tout de
[Applaudissements]
suite